welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Larsen Wolverine's MCU arrival is upon
us with unconverted reports circulating
that henry cavill is a talks for the
role all based on the rock hard evidence
that it takes multiple franchises to
contain cabals guns i'm gonna break down
everything you actually need to know
about this henry cavill wolverine news
and how whomever kevin feige surgically
enhances with adamantium claws the
Marvel Cinematic Universe has actually
set itself up with several ways or Logan
is beaten buddies to show up spoiler
warning in case my theories end up
spoiling this Henry Cavill Wolverine
movie that will definitely happen after
this Cavill Wolverine chatter broke the
internet we've been able to trace this
all back to a gossip site with a news
article claiming sources about Henry
Cavill as Wolverine in Captain Marvel 2
now there have been some rumors that
Marvel has been meeting with cavil
generally as they do with pretty much
everyone in Hollywood including Keanu
but cavils a bit busy shooting the next
season the witcher on it flicks and
counting is a bit busy shooting
everything so based on that alone like
the beds wand is meeting kids sleeping
this kind of Wolverine rumor is duplo's
I'm not sorry there has also been some
talk that Captain Marvel 2 will feature
a mutant but a different one rogue based
on the very interesting relationship
between broke and Carole in the comics
but even if that's true
Captain Marvel 2 is set to release
sometime in 2022 or beyond and I think
it's possible that the MCU reveals its
mutants and possibly if it's Wolverine
before that and one of the movies in
streamit series we have coming up I see
four theories weird one
mutants already exists in the MCU we
just haven't been looking hard enough or
our heads have just been turned in the
wrong direction from the dawn of the MCU
Kevin Feige considered mutants as much
part of his universe as the Hulk and
spider-man bikes and assorted mutants
weren't enough assorted mutants Fury's
making it sound like life in the MCU is
like a box of chocolates and you never
know if you're gonna get a Wolverine
last time he trusted a caramel Pete
Lawson ah another alternate version of a
phase 1 scene included this mentioned by
Tony Stark of a mysterious shield
program and ship stuff out of storage
can everything from projects Pegasus
exhibition Goliath later MCU films have
revealed what project Pegasus and
project Goliath work but Exodus has
remained a mystery
I have speculated it could be a secret
government weapon X
program an exodus of mutants from
society to a secure location now I know
you're saying hey the x-men were in the
MC the whole time where are they been
why didn't they help against Ultron or
Thanos and yes I can read your thoughts
now that I know other channels are
breaking down my breakdowns and now I am
breaking down there break down break
downs down the rabbit hole we go
consider that there had been other
fronts to these past MCU conflicts that
the camera hasn't pointed at much like
how endgame revealed the ancient one to
be fighting Loki's Chitauri alongside
everyone else we just never saw it him
perhaps elsewhere around the world
mutants like Wolverine were in the fight
just on an unseen corner of sokovia or
behind a pile of Avengers HQ rubble that
spider-man didn't swing over i theorize
that mutants could have been quietly
preventing disasters from getting worse
over the generations like maybe the
Eternals film were revealed that the
deviance of ancient times led to
evolutionary descendants with a mutant
x-gene look the truth is you never know
what is lurking beyond what's visible to
the naked eye sometimes as a character's
nefarious agenda sometimes they're just
grouchy because parts of them are
tugging other parts because they haven't
been taking care of those parts like
there wellthanks do manscaped for
sponsoring this episode yeah
landscape is the only mens brand
directed to below the waist grooming and
hygiene we love the products of manscape
even more than getting to make
sophomoric jokes or manscaped around
these parts there's nothing better for
our parts you might even say our love
for the company grows when we get
excited but let's quit beating around
the carefully trim bush just when you
thought they'd have it all figured out
manscape takes things up a notch with
the brand-new lawnmower 3.0 waterproof
body trimmer see it Wow wide swamp that
way you can see each pube as you cut it
hope you didn't name those suckers
because they're now snipped snips the
new and improved perfect package 3.0 kit
includes this new lawnmower 3.0 trimmer
plus a ton of great add-ons to make for
the perfect grooming experience for the
modern man ching-ching it's like a Vegas
weekend for your nutsack manscaped is
available at Target stores nationwide
but when you purchase the perfect
package 3.0 kit online at manscape com
you get the biggest bang for your buck
there's a free thank-you gift and every
replenishment this cycle I got the new
plow 2.0 se
a razor an exclusive offer for
subscribers only and because you're a
new rockstars viewer you're gonna get
not one but two free gifts they shed
travel bag and the landscape to
boxer-briefs you're not getting these
you're gonna get your own if you want
mine just stop telling me get 20% off
plus free shipping from your perfect
package 3.0 purchase when you use the
promo code new rack at manscaped calm
that's code new rack for 20% off at
manscape comm also check out our
Instagram P for a special giveaway
promotion but if you insist some
canonical mention of other mutants to
buy the explanation try wool boring
dirty to utens did not exist previously
on the MCU but recent MCU events have
created them and endgame rocket
described the snap in an interesting way
when Dino snapped his fingers earth
became ground zero for a power surge of
ridiculously cosmic proportions no one's
ever seen anything like it so with more
snaps that's a lot of gamma radiation
spread across the universe it's got to
be some side effects like say a child
born with tissue regenerative enough to
withstand skeletal adamantium implants
additionally ant-man the wasp
established that enhanced abilities like
phase shifting and healing powers are
side effects of quantum particles
adaptation is part of it but some of it
is evolution if the quantum realm exists
on a subatomic level throughout
everything perhaps on a more macro level
these particles exist in higher
quantities in certain life forms which
in them result in mutant abilities
abilities that are now manifesting in
individuals everywhere now that might
require the mc2 retcon and change many
of the classic x-men characters origins
like you know Logan actually dates back
to the mid 19th century magneto to world
war ii apocalypse to ancient times table
- who the hell knows Feige has entered
he wants to do something different with
the MCU mutants but if you wants to try
to stay true to those origins
you could try Marie Curie three mutants
already exist roughly as we know their
comic backstories but in a different
hardline the way endgame left the MCU
the most direct way to introduce mutants
into this universe is just say the whole
time they've been in a different verse
using time-travel Steve Rogers lived a
second life in a timeline we never got
to see and now Loki appears to be
dealing with the consequences of that in
game time meddling with the time
variance Authority Marvel's time cops
coming into play
one of those hypothetical timelines
overseen by the TVA could be one in
which among the Avengers we've known or
additional names like Logan Scott
Summers Charles Xavier and that timeline
could be the one Loki tumbles into and
the one we stay in like we leave the
earth 1 9999 behind forever and stay in
earth 200,000 earth-616 whatever you
want to call it but that would be
assuming that the muddy time-travel
logic of endgame will be the rules by
which the whole Marvel Universe operates
in the future mutant life can find a
better way for example your very very
for mutants exist in a different reality
of the multiverse we know from upcoming
titles like Doctor Strange in the
multiverse madness and one division that
Marvel was about to rewrite the rules of
reality perhaps they'll build on the way
and game shattered reality but time
travel or maybe the fabric of reality
will be warped by Scarlet Witch we've
theorized that one division could be a
loose adaption of the House of M event
which features wander resetting reality
with and without mutants the teaser for
the series hinted the existence of her
mutant children Wiccan and speed who do
play a big role in house of M as does
Wolverine Wolverine is the one mutants
who remembers the world as it was before
Wanda flipped reality so that means are
now the dominant social class and it is
on Logan to reawaken each Marvel hero so
that they can flip things back if this
one division series features Wanda
chaotically flipping reality through
genres as if flipping through TV
channels perhaps the antagonist who
arrives to stop her is a mutant from one
of these alternate realities she's
flying through the one mutants with
regenerative nerve cells whose mind
remains intact across the spectrum of
existence and his name is Deadpool
I mean Wolverine for more of our
unfiltered thoughts on this Wolverine
news join our official discord server by
becoming a patron of new rock stars at
patreon.com slash new rock stars who do
you think should play Wolverine in the
MCU comment down below follow me on
instagram or twitter ITA vas following
new rockstars and subscribe to nirach
sirs here on YouTube for breakdowns of
everything you look thanks for watching
[Music]